lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
pensar cómo la fuerza normal sería
distinta en escenarios diferentes y como
mi hijo de dos años y medio está
obsesionado con los elevadores pensé que
podría enfocarme en ellos así que aquí
dibujé cuatro situaciones en el primero
tenemos lo siguiente vamos a tener que
en este digamos que pueden ser digamos
cuatro etapas de un mismo movimiento del
elevador digamos que al inicio pues
tiene una velocidad de cero metros sobre
segundo ok y por supuesto pues como
podrás imaginarte la aceleración será
también de cero metros sobre segundo al
cuadrado muy bien entonces aquí a lo
mejor es cuando me estoy subiendo al
elevador y quizás puedo yo poner fuego
más bien es apretar el botón y entonces
el elevador empieza a subir y digamos
que al empezar a subir tiene una
aceleración tiene una aceleración de 2
metros
sobre segundo al cuadrado y recordemos
que tanto la velocidad como la
aceleración son cantidades bueno son son
son vectores verdad en realidad todo
esto son vectores yo le podría poner
podríamos hacer la convención de que
cuando hable de positivo en realidad es
una aceleración hacia arriba y cuando
hable de negativo sea una aceleración
hacia abajo o bien puedo poner que esto
va en la dirección del vector unitario
jota el vector unitario jota es
justamente el vector de magnitud o de
norma uno que va hacia arriba entonces
vamos a dejarlo así con el vector con el
vector j muy bien entonces esta es
nuestra segunda situación la tercera es
a lo mejor llevó después de un segundo
deja de acelerar y solo se mantiene a
una velocidad constante ok entonces
nuestra velocidad es de dos metros sobre
segundo en la dirección j
dijimos que va a dejar de acelerar
entonces la aceleración es de 0 metros
sobre segundo al cuadrado y podría
ponerle la jota pero bueno como tiene el
cero con eso basta muy bien entonces qué
pasa cuando a lo mejor ya estoy casi
llegando al al piso que yo deseo
entonces el elevador empieza a
desacelerar y tendremos una aceleración
negativa es decir tendremos por ejemplo
una aceleración de menos dos metros
sobre segundo al cuadrado y nuevamente
en la dirección j sólo que como lleva el
signo menos en vez de apuntar hacia
arriba va a apuntar hacia abajo muy bien
entonces estas son nuestras cuatro
situaciones y lo que lo que quiero que
hagamos en este vídeo es pensar cuál es
la fuerza normal que que el suelo del
elevador ejerce en este personaje que
pueden ser ustedes o puede que sea yo en
estas cuatro situaciones ok vamos para
esto a suponer que nos encontramos cerca
de la superficie de la tierra
para que el efecto gravitacional sea más
o menos constante ok entonces para poder
resolver este problema primero
necesitamos determinar cuál es la masa
de este de este personaje digamos que es
un niño
ok digamos que este es un niño y que
tiene una masa de 10 kilogramos tiene
una masa de 10 kilogramos y por supuesto
pues no sé quizás no está comiendo
galletas así que este niño tiene 10
kilogramos de masa en todas estas
situaciones ok entonces cuando digo que
en realidad tiene una masa ay que no hay
que confundir cuando cuando hablamos del
peso porque el peso en realidad es la
fuerza debida al efecto gravitacional
que hay del centro de la tierra a
nosotros muy bien es decir es la fuerza
que nos mantiene unidos a la tierra de
hecho lo que sí necesitamos es calcular
cuál es la fuerza gravitacional qué o
cuál es el campo gravitacional que se
ejerce debido a nuestra masa
y sabemos que la fuerza gravitacional
cambia ligeramente a medida que nos
vamos distanciando del centro de la
tierra pero vamos a suponer que
esencialmente es constante está esta
aceleración la aceleración debida a la
gravedad es de menos 9.8 metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado y por supuesto otra
vez en la dirección j es decir la la
aceleración va hacia el centro de la
tierra que es en esta dirección muy bien
entonces lo que necesitamos ahora es
determinar cuál es la fuerza de gravedad
que ejerce la tierra sobre nosotros muy
bien entonces si consideramos aquí a
este a este personaje a este niño
entonces la fuerza gravitacional irá
hacia abajo que entonces eso se ve de
aquí porque es la aceleración tiene un
signo menos y quiere decir que va hacia
abajo muy bien entonces recordemos de la
segunda ley de newton que la fuerza
es igual a la masa por la aceleración
aquí tenemos la masa que es de 10
kilogramos verdad y si multiplicamos por
la aceleración que es esta g tendremos
10 x menos 9.8 esta fuerza gravitacional
la fuerza de vida la gravedad desde
menos 98 kilogramos metros sobre segundo
al cuadrado que son newtons y otra vez
va en la dirección j
entonces lo que nos está diciendo es que
al inicio de este problema tenemos una
aceleración de 0 metros sobre segundo al
cuadrado quiere decir que nuestra fuerza
neta es de 0 ok
este este personaje no le está
infringiendo nada una fuerza aunque no
hay no hay nada que le esté imprimiendo
una fuerza de este personaje sin embargo
aquí tenemos una fuerza que va hacia
abajo y bueno en realidad cuando digo
que no le imprime una fuerza en realidad
es que todas las fuerzas que actúan
sobre este niño
se cancelan son son balanceadas y
entonces lo que yo necesito es encontrar
una fuerza que vaya en dirección
contraria que es hacia arriba verdad y
que neutralice esta fuerza debida a la
gravedad esto es exactamente la fuerza
normal y para que se cancele con la
fuerza gravitacional entonces éste tiene
que ser de 98 newtons en la dirección
positiva ok es de 98 newtons y así la
fuerza que
qué suma es 0 y por lo tanto tendremos
una aceleración de 0 metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado vamos a ver qué pasa
en la segunda situación aquí tenemos una
aceleración de 2 metros sobre segundo al
cuadrado en esta dirección
cuál sería entonces la fuerza neta vamos
a escribirlo así fuerza neta que se
ejerce sobre este personaje entonces
nuevamente es la masa por la aceleración
que tenemos 10 kilogramos 10 kilogramos
por 2
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado en la
dirección j y que esto simplemente es 10
por 2 que son 20 kilogramos metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado que son los newtons
ok en la dirección j entonces la fuerza
neta que actúa sobre este niño es de 20
newtons en dirección digamos hacia
arriba ok en el sentido positivo ok
entonces si nosotros tenemos aquí la
fuerza gravitacional la fuerza
gravitacional que sabemos que es de
menos 98 newtons cuál tendría que ser la
fuerza la fuerza normal la fuerza normal
para que tengamos no sólo que se
contrarreste la de la gravedad sino que
además tengamos 20 newtons hacia arriba
entonces primero para contrarrestar la
fuerza de gravedad
necesitamos 98 newtons y luego
necesitamos otros 20 para que al final
nos queden 20 newtons verdad entonces sí
necesitamos 98 y 20
y eso nos da 118 newtons en esta
dirección muy bien en la dirección
positiva perdón en la dirección hacia
arriba es decir en sentido positivo
vamos a ver qué ocurre en la tercera
situación tenemos que el elevador dejó
de acelerar pero nos mantenemos a una
velocidad constante de dos metros sobre
segundo entonces tú podrías pensar en
principio que pues como tenemos cierta
velocidad necesitamos cierta fuerza para
mantenernos de esa forma pero aquí es en
donde tienes que recordar la primera ley
de newton que nos dice que si un cuerpo
se mantiene en su estado de reposo o
movimiento rectilíneo uniforme que es
nuestro caso verdad
mantenemos una velocidad constante hacia
arriba en línea recta entonces aquí
utilizamos la primera ley de newton y
nos dice que es si para mantener que en
realidad cualquier cuerpo permanece en
ese estado a menos de que se le imprima
una fuerza
y desbalanceada en este caso cómo se
mantiene a velocidad constante lo único
que necesitamos es contrarrestar la
fuerza de gravedad para que se mantenga
a velocidad constante y para para eso
esencialmente es igual que el primer
ejemplo entonces nuestra fuerza normal
es de 98 newtons en la dirección del
vector j ok y recuerda que en realidad
el niño que está en el elevador a lo
mejor si no puede oír que la maquinaria
está encendida pues el niño no sabe si
está en reposo o en movimiento
rectilíneo uniforme de verdad entonces
realmente son como como análogos estos
casos muy bien entonces
vamos a ver qué pasa en el último
ejemplo en el último ejemplo tenemos
este ni este mismo niño pero ahora
nuestra aceleración es de menos dos
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado en la
dirección j muy bien entonces quién
sería nuestra fuerza neta quién sería
nuestra fuerza neta pues sería masa por
aceleración es decir 10 kilogramos 10
kilogramos por menos 2 metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado en la dirección j y
esto ahora es menos 20 newtons en la
dirección j muy bien entonces esta es
una fuerza que va hacia abajo muy bien
entonces tenemos una fuerza de gravedad
tenemos esta fuerza de gravedad que es
de menos 98 newtons cuál tendría que ser
entonces la fuerza normal para tener una
una aceleración de menos 2 metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado
pues la fuerza neta tiene que ser de
menos 20 newtons pero aquí tenemos menos
98 así que cuánto hay que sumar para
obtener solo menos 20 minutos pues serán
78 newtons verdad la fuerza normal será
78 newtons en la dirección del vector
jota y si te das cuenta si sumas menos
98 y 78 te da menos 20 ok entonces no
estamos compensando la la fuerza de
gravedad pero nos quedamos con menos 20
newtons en la dirección del vector j y
ahora me gustaría mucho que pensaras
esto la próxima vez que subas a un
elevador el único movimiento en que
percibes que algo está pasando es cuando
el elevador está acelerando o
desacelerando
cuando está acelerando es cuando tu
cuerpo se siente muy pesado incluso
puedes intentar brincar y verás que es
muy complicado mientras que cuando está
desacelerando es más ligero entonces te
invito a que pienses por qué ocurre esto
pero si si tienes que recordar que el
reposo
en realidad la velocidad constante que
sientes cuando cuando llevas una
velocidad con dos personas más bien el
cuando estás en reposo o en velocidad
constante en realidad si estás en el
elevador puedes sentirte igual que si
estás en la súper
y si de la tierra